This multiplication, simplifies to this expression. Now this might look really
complicated, but it's not too tough to get there. First, we distribute the cube
root of 4xy to each of the terms in our second parentheses. When we multiply
these two cube roots together, we'll get 64, x cubed, y cubed. So we know this
distribution gives us this first term. Now we want to distribute this to the
second term. For the second term, we'll have the cube root of 12, and then xy,
from these variables here. Next we distribute the cube root of 2 to this term.
So we'll have the cube root of 32x squared y squared. And finally for our last
term we'll have the cubed root of 2 times the cubed root of 3. Which equals the
cube root of 6. Next we try to simplify any of the radicals that we can. The
cubed root of 64 equals 4. And the cubed root of x cubed y cubed is xy. This
radical is already simplified since there's no factor that repeats 3 times
underneath the radical, so we leave it as is. We can't simplify the x squared y
squared since we don't have a group of 3. But we can simplify 32 here, since 32
is the same thing as 8 times 4. The cubed root of 8 equals 2, and this leads us
to our answer. On the end here, the cubed root of 6 can't be simplified, so we
have to tack it onto the end. There's no like terms here since none of the
radicands are equal. So we're done. This is our final answer.